of May 2017 at the Manchester Arena
22 people were murdered
and over 1 000 injured in a planned
indiscriminate
and cowardly Act of abject barbarity
today our thoughts
are with bereaved families and the
survivors who have been Central to
everything we have done
since this attack took place
this inquiry set out to leave no stone
unturned in its effort to provide
answers about what happened on the night
of the attack
the comprehensive report that we have
received this morning
records the very detailed summation of
Sir John Saunders findings and is the
embodiment of the Care taken by him to
fulfill its purpose
we recognize that many aspects of the
latest published volume
will make for difficult and distressing
reading for those most affected
on behalf of Grace Manchester please I
thank the inquiry team for the
opportunities that we have been given
to participate fully and fairly in the
inquiry process and we welcome today's
report
I fully accept the findings of the chair
Sir John Saunders
Beyond the selflessness and
professionalism of so many of our
Frontline staff it is also clear
that our coordination of the response to
this atrocity was poor
we have failed to plan effectively and
the execution of that which was planned
was simply not good enough
our actions were substantially
inadequate and fell short of what the
public have every right to expect
and for this I apologize unreservedly
our failure to affect proper command and
control of the incident from the outset
undermined an effective multi-agency
response to a dreadful set of
circumstances
we did not act upon learning from
previous exercises which could have
produced the burden or impact felt on
the force duty officer
for communications per planning
inadequate training and shortcomings in
strategic leadership all played a part
in our failure
all of these failings could and should
have been identified and mitigated
through learning from robustly designed
training exercises under the auspices of
our local resilience forum
alas these were opportunities that were
not sufficiently taken
sadly gmps combined failings were
significant
to the families and loved ones of those
who died I am truly sorry
it is important that we now take the
time to carefully consider every facet
of the volume published today and we
have a dedicated team already in place
for this purpose
but I also want to reassure the public
that we have not waited for the
publication of today's findings before
making a number of substantial and
beneficial changes to our operating
model
in recent years GMP has strengthened its
leadership of all levels and has placed
a premium on core operational confidence
and effectiveness
we have developed a detailed memorandum
of understanding with British transport
police for the arena site amongst others
to ensure absolute Clarity between our
organizations as to roles and
responsibilities
we have now a rigorous process to ensure
the greater testing and practical
awareness of multi-agency communication
methods to the point today where their
use is second nature
GMP has dramatically enhanced our
commitment to the greater Manchester
local Brazilians form and indeed one of
our senior officers currently chairs
this important element of our joint
preparedness
we have completed the wholesale reform
of our Force control room function
significant investment has enabled
single site working additional Staffing
and enhanced training we have improved
the way that we debrief critical
incidents so as to better capture and
share organizational learning we've
invested substantially in improved first
aid training and equipment for all our
Frontline offices for example all GMP
vehicles have been issued with enhanced
first aid kits which include tourniques
and we have significantly enhanced the
number of defibrillators routinely
available to our staff
in short I am already able to
confidently state that GMP is now in a
fundamentally stronger position than it
was in 2017 should we be called upon to
lead and respond to a similarly
challenging and terrible event
I say this not least because GMP and our
partner agencies have sadly had to apply
our combined resources to a number of
real life major incident responses since
2017.
in these circumstances the fact that we
have reviewed and tested our
multi-agency responses have proven
beneficial
in delivering the professional and
well-coordinated operational effect
required
I'm also able to provide an assurance
that our learning is currently being
widely shared
whilst the inquiry has considered
a dreadful event in Greater Manchester
the eyes of policing nationally are upon
this report
we have already established a clear
means of disseminating the learning
throughout policing under the auspices
of the National Police Chiefs Council
and through the counter-terrorism police
Network
as I have already indicated we now have
more work to do and will do so in earned
I would like to stress the point that
because of the terrible events at the
arena that night we do things
differently and better
on the night many of our officers ran
bravely straight into the face of danger
and gave them their very best to help
those injured by any means necessary
with courage determination and
compassion and with without regard to
their own safety
and I am grateful to the chair for his
acknowledgments of their commitment and
for the positive words written of their
contribution
I'm also proud of the painstaking and
exemplary criminal investigation which
followed the attack
and led to the extradition and
conviction of Obama's brother
on 22 counts of murder with a minimum
term of 55 years imprisonment
the horrific nature of that which is
still being endured by so many drives us
to ensure that we will never repeat
these failings
in this the public can be confident of
our resolve
this is the very least of what GMP can
offer to those who are still suffering
a fierce determination to ensure that
your loss and hurt will not be in vain
ladies and gentlemen I would now like to
introduce to you Chief Constable Lucy
lawsuits and chief Constable for British
transport please he'll make a statement
of Iran
foreign
good afternoon everyone
here in this city 22 people were
murdered by the evil actions of
terrorists and hundreds of lives were
changed forever
we will never forget them and those who
must live with a pain they don't deserve
to feel
today we heard the recommendations made
by Sir John Saunders and the Manchester
inquiry team
British transport police accepts their
findings and recommendations and I thank
them for allowing us to fully
participate in the inquiry
significant errors were made in the
hours leading up to this horrendous
attack and in the immediate aftermath
our planning and preparation was
inadequate to respond to an incident of
this magnitude
for those errors I want to apologize to
the families of the victims and to every
one of you affected by that terrible
night
on behalf of everyone in British
transport police I am truly sorry
there were mistakes and misjudgments but
there was also compassion and bravery
police officers and staff who ran
towards the attack without hesitation as
well as security staff and members of
the public
in the time that has passed those
responders have also carried the trauma
of that night
they too deserve our support
this is a part of etp's History which we
will never forget
and as you would expect today's report
does not Mark the start of our
improvements but it acts as an
invaluable Aid to build on the
improvements we have already made and
are continuing to make since May 2017.
we are already working more closely than
ever with the agencies alongside me here
today committing to programs of joint
exercising and testing so that we are
better prepared
our major incident plan has been
reviewed simplified and improved and our
officers are better trained including
those in key command roles
mbtp one of our values is that we strive
to be better every day
this means continually improving our
planning and response to Major incidents
the changes we have made and those that
are planned mean we are in a much
stronger position to respond effectively
with our partners to incidents of this
nature across the railways of England
Scotland and Wales
the families and friends of the victims
and the City of Manchester will continue
to grieve for years to come
we share this heartache not just as an
organization but as individuals
no learning can turn back the clock
no apology can lend a broken heart
we can only reflect on today's reports
with Canada and I absolutely promise you
we will do better
I'm now going to pass over to David
Russell Chief Fire officer
good afternoon everyone
the Manchester Arena inquiry for you two
reports
it's made for very difficult reading for
me this G5 officer of Greater Manchester
fine rescue service and my colleagues
I want to start by wholeheartedly
apologizing
the families of the 22 innocent people
who lost their lives on that tragic
night of the 22nd of May
2017 and to the survivors whose lives
have changed forever
our response that night
was holy inadequate and totally
ineffective
and that will forever be a matter of
deep regrets for our service
we let the families and the public down
in their time of need
and for that I am truly sorry
I know that no apology will take away
the pain and suffering of the families
who lost loved ones and of the survivors
but I want them to know that I fully
accept
the inquiries criticisms of our service
and I accept the recommendations in full
I also want to thank Mr John Saunders
for his work throughout the inquiry and
in producing this report
the inquiries process has been one of
the most challenging times in our
services history
and today is a very difficult day for
many
especially those
who so desperately wanted to help that
night
every firefighter who joins greater
Manchester fire rescue service
wants to do their best
the best job they can to help to support
to assist the public and save lives
those that will eventually deploy to the
incident at night
did the best job they could or be it it
was far too late
while we have already made significant
changes to address the failings
in how we responded on the night
the inquiries recommendations provide a
critically important framework for
ensuring we take all the necessary steps
to always
be ready and able to respond to a
terrorist attack anywhere in our city
region
the report is long and complex it will
take time to digest the recommendations
fully from cross-reference them against
improvements which we have already put
in place and to consider whether any
gaps remain I do however want to address
a few issues the report raises
as I've said and the inquiry knows we
were simply too late in our response
or five years on from the attack I want
the public to know that this will never
happen again
today's greater Manchester fire rescue
service he's better prepared
better equipped better trained better
exercise and more resilient
occurs like if you set up by the mayor
of Greater Manchester after the attack
identify a number of recommendations
which we've already put in place to
improve and drive meaningful change
within our service and these changes
have been tested during the multi-agency
response to many major incidents in
recent years
we knew immediately after the arena of
attack that there had been a complete
failure the multi-agency working
the inquiry report makes that clear and
this has been a major Focus for us since
the attack
there has been a substantial shift in
the leadership and culture of our
service
recognized positively by these Majesty's
inspectors of constabulary and Fire
Rescue Services
we've undertaken an age of overhaul of
our policies and procedures in relation
to a terrorist incident
revising and simplifying our mobilizing
Arrangements which ensure an automatic
response to the scene
the dedicated radio channel is now
established which guarantees immediate
contact 24 7. between blue light
services and our control rooms
in addition to this the national
interagency liaison officer is now
co-located with gmp's Force duty officer
during working hours with a dedicated
emergency phone line for all of the
times
there's greater investment in training
multi-agency exercising and increased
emphasis on decision-making autonomy
meaning incident commanders can
confidently make decisions with
discretion
wholesale changes have been made to
organizational learning and our debrief
processes
as well as major improvements in how we
communicate and work together with our
partner agencies during and after
incidents in conjunction with Northwest
Fire Control and importantly Across The
Wider greater Manchester resilience
forum
we have also established a more
resilient marauding terrorist attack
capability for greater Manchester
by increasing our capacity and
capability which sees every firefighter
being fully trained and every fire
Appliance better equipped to respond to
all forms of terrorists or mass casualty
in Sudan
another Spotlight today is rightly on
what our service got wrong on the night
of the attack
and I want to reiterate my deepest
apologies to the families
and survivors
I want the public to know the same
mistakes would not be made today and
have confidence that never again will we
fall short of what the public should
really expect of their fire and rescue
service
I hope that the public will recognize
that greater Manchester fine rescue
service is a very different organization
today to what he was in 2017.
and that's the improvements we've made
and continue to make will provide
confidence that we are prepared and able
to respond to support the people of
Greater Manchester when it's Fire and
Rescue Services are needed
thank you I'd now like to introduce
Darren mockery
chief executive of Northwest Ambulance
Service
good afternoon for everyone connected
with the atrocity on the 22nd of May
2017. the last five years have already
produced painful reminders of that
night's events
and although I'm well aware this day has
been a long time coming for many I know
a feeling of pain loss fear and anger do
not go away
my thoughts and sympathies are with you
all particularly with the Reese families
and the injured
we will never forget the prevent impact
of the attack on you every member of the
ambulance service and the communities we
serve
I hope that these reports can give some
answers however I understand that the
answers may not be what everyone was
looking for
I accept the findings and I thank Sir
John Saunders and his team for their
diligence
all those participants specifically
speaking and emergency response that
night if so trying to do their best and
save lives and repeatedly did just that
Brave actions which help many people
staying with them in their time of need
and in administering ongoing care
not just those from the ambulance
service but of course workers from other
Emergency Services any case and members
of the public
to all of you you should be incredibly
proud of your efforts your interventions
will not be forgotten by the people who
received it
tragically as we're all aware 22 people
didn't survive that night and many
others have seriously injured
when people do lose their lives we
understand that this however performance
will ultimately be judged and that's
quite likely is the case today
the number of responders treating people
in the city room has been a great
concern to many and as frequently
mentioned in the report
we have said that more of our staff
should have been deployed into the city
room to help triage patients and manage
their evacuation
what also produces deeper debt is that
the ability to work together as we like
Partners they are well short standards
we all expected
the principles of multi-agency working
are incredibly important to the way we
deal with needed incidents they should
never have broken down so quickly and so
drastically
we take another share of the
responsibility for that
we failed to communicate situational
awareness reports
we failed to share our regions and
regulations and we failed to establish
adequate communication between the
control rooms and each other
also obviously we are during the inquiry
is how we fail to learn from previous
joint training exercises
if you say we have no athletes I admit
seemed a little too late nonetheless
it's important we do
since the going we have taken a series
of important steps to True recaptive
learning and initiate change
improved communication between emergency
control rooms and enhance our staff's
awareness of multi-agency capabilities
within major incidents
we have updated our region incident
plans and introduced new specific
policies for the arena and shared fees
with our operator and our blue light
partners
what's more to prepare the commanders
more effectively we have enhanced their
training and made it more rigorous and
sustained so our skills are maintained
and frequently refreshed
of course there is much more still to
digest from the report and a chair
recommendations
I'd Advocate on responsibility to make
sure progress is made on them
and in my other role as a chair of the
association of Hampton's Chief
Executives I will endorse changes
required of our national Partners to
improve Andrew's responses all over the
country
I am confident that if something like
this happens again the response will
have more effective preparation
management and coordination between blue
light Partners here today
I also believe that everyone I telling
us we strive to respond with
professionalism compassion and a desire
to help
on occasions like this the one sorry as
a risk of sending home
nevertheless I want to make it clear
that while cell actions were well
intentioned we apologize wholeheartedly
for our failures
they were heavily honest individually
and as an organization
lastly I want to use this opportunity to
invite the families of those who have
lost loved ones should they wish to meet
with us and ask any questions they have
thank you